I know it's early in the year, but we're already talking about our summer family trip. And you know we like to Airbnb. I know this. Well, we like to have a kitchen and I like to be able to walk out in my robe in the morning and have a cup of tea and as you call it, Jenna, I like a long runway. Yes. Well, you know, Lee is working in Oklahoma right now and we're going to come out to visit him and he got us a really nice Airbnb to stay in as a whole family. So that we could spread out, and everybody could sleep well. And then you feel like you're at home,
我知道现在才年初，但我们已经在讨论暑假的家庭旅行了。你知道我们喜欢住爱彼迎（Airbnb）。我知道。嗯，我们喜欢有厨房，我喜欢早上能穿着睡袍走出来喝杯茶，正如你所说的，珍娜，我喜欢一段长长的跑道。是的。嗯，你知道，李现在在俄克拉荷马州工作，我们要去看他，他为我们全家找了一个非常好的爱彼迎住处。这样我们就能分散开来，每个人都能睡个好觉。然后你会感觉就像在家里一样，
even though you're in a different city. Lady, I don't wanna sleep in the same room as my whole family. That's why I can't do hotels great anymore. Yeah, cause you all bunk up, and share a bathroom. Yeah, I like the space. I like a refrigerator, a real refrigerator. I like to have snacks, as you know, I don't know this. Yes, I don't want to call room service. I want them right there. That's right.
即使你身处不同的城市。天哪，我可不想和全家人住在一个房间里。这就是为什么我再也受不了酒店了。是的，因为你们都挤在一起，共用一个浴室。是的，我喜欢空间。我喜欢冰箱，一个真正的冰箱。我喜欢有零食，如你所知，我不知道这个。是的，我不想叫客房服务。我想要它们就在手边。没错。
Yeah. Everyone were ladies who Airbnb I guess for your next adventure for your next vacation, maybe consider Airbnb. At Desjardins, we speak business. We speak startup funding and comprehensive game plans. We've mastered made-to-measure growth and expansion advice, and we can talk your ear off about transferring your business when the time comes. Because at Desjardins Business, we speak the same language you do, business. So join the more than 400,000 Canadian entrepreneurs who already count on us and contact Desjardins today. We'd love to talk business. Hello everyone and welcome to your second drink of The Secret. You might remember back in the Booze Cruise episode,
是的。每个人都是爱彼迎的粉丝，我想对于你的下一次冒险，你的下一次假期，也许可以考虑爱彼迎。在德雅丹（Desjardins），我们谈论商业。我们谈论创业资金和全面的商业计划。我们精通量身定制的增长和扩张建议，当时候到了，我们可以跟你聊个没完关于如何转让你的企业。因为在德雅丹商业，我们说的是同一种语言，那就是商业。所以加入超过40万名已经信赖我们的加拿大企业家行列，今天就联系德雅丹吧。我们很乐意谈谈生意。大家好，欢迎来到《办公室女郎》的第二杯“秘密”。你可能还记得在“酒水游轮”那一集里，
Michael finds out that Jim has feelings for Pam. And this is the episode where Jim is forced to go to lunch with Michael at Hooters to make sure that Michael keeps his secret. Michael is so delighted to have this like bond with Jim over this secret. Well, while they're at Hooters, he orders a gourmet hot dog. And the first time we broke down this episode, we wondered, does Hooters have gourmet hot dogs? I couldn't find them on the online website, but thanks to all of you, we may have solved the mystery. We got mail.
迈克尔发现吉姆对帕姆有感觉。这一集里，吉姆被迫和迈克尔一起去猫头鹰餐厅（Hooters）吃午饭，以确保迈克尔保守他的秘密。迈克尔因为这个秘密与吉姆建立了这种联系而感到非常高兴。嗯，当他们在猫头鹰餐厅时，他点了一个美味热狗。我们第一次分析这一集时，我们想，猫头鹰餐厅有美味热狗吗？我在网上没找到，但多亏了你们大家，我们可能解开了这个谜团。我们收到邮件了。
Kenya H said, yes, they do, or at least they did have them and they were delicious. And Liz C said, I had a hot dog at the Coral Gables Hooters in Miami. So there's two people who have had the Hooters hot dog. However, Tatian R said, I worked at Hooters in Las Vegas for several years and we never served gourmet hot dogs or ham and cheese sandwiches. It's looking like this is going to be a mom detective's moment. Well, the mighty Danny may have solved the mystery. He said,
肯尼亚·H说，是的，他们有，或者至少他们曾经有过，而且非常美味。利兹·C说，我在迈阿密的珊瑚阁猫头鹰餐厅吃过热狗。所以有两个人吃过猫头鹰餐厅的热狗。然而，塔蒂安·R说，我在拉斯维加斯的猫头鹰餐厅工作了好几年，我们从来没有供应过美味热狗或火腿芝士三明治。看起来这要成为一个“妈妈侦探”时刻了。嗯，强大的丹尼可能解开了这个谜团。他说，
My wife used to work at Hooters. She can confirm that they did indeed serve gourmet hot dogs and ham and cheese sandwiches during that time period. They were taken off the menu around 2010. Thank you, the mighty Danny. Look at that. A mom detective's moment. Solved. Rare, but happens sometimes. Sometimes. Well, we also talked a lot about casual Fridays in this breakdown. Angela, you noted that this episode happens on a Friday, and yet we are not dressed casually.
我妻子以前在猫头鹰餐厅工作。她可以证实，在那段时间里，他们确实供应过美味热狗和火腿芝士三明治。它们在2010年左右被从菜单上撤下了。谢谢你，强大的丹尼。你看。一个“妈妈侦探”时刻。解决了。虽然罕见，但有时会发生。有时。嗯，我们在这次分析中也谈了很多关于“休闲星期五”的话题。安吉拉，你指出这一集发生在周五，但我们并没有穿休闲装。
And a lot of people wrote in to say that later in a Michael Scott paper company episode, there is a reference to casual Fridays being reinstated. So somewhere along the line, it's clear that they were canceled. Paper Company episode, there is a reference to Casual Fridays being reinstated. So somewhere along the line, it's clear that they were canceled. Yes. And once we got to Michael Scott Paper Company, things were explained a little, but I still stand by my argument that the whole Casual Friday thing was a little loosey-goosey. I agree.
很多人写信来说，后来在“迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司”那一集里，提到了“休闲星期五”被恢复了。所以很明显，在某个时间点，它们被取消了。造纸公司那一集，提到了“休闲星期五”被恢复了。所以很明显，在某个时间点，它们被取消了。是的。当我们到了“迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司”那一集时，事情解释得清楚了一些，但我仍然坚持我的观点，即整个“休闲星期五”的事情有点随意。我同意。
We also got this letter from Helena N., who has this to say about Casual Fridays. Casual Fridays is a hot topic over in the Office Ladies mailbag, let me tell you. Helena said, Hi Office Ladies, so after listening to the secret episode of your show three times, I have a theory about Casual Fridays. Helena, thank you for listening three times. I know. In my mind, Casual Fridays are a monthly thing, but are also an incentive for the office, like as a reward for a good month's work. Oh.
我们还收到了海伦娜·N的这封信，她对“休闲星期五”有话要说。“休闲星期五”在《办公室女郎》的邮件袋里是一个热门话题，我告诉你。海伦娜说，嗨，《办公室女郎》，在听了你们节目的“秘密”那一集三次之后，我对“休闲星期五”有一个理论。海伦娜，谢谢你听了三次。我知道。在我看来，“休闲星期五”是每月一次的事情，也是对办公室的一种激励，就像是对一个月辛勤工作的奖励。哦。
But because Michael is always getting in trouble with corporate or having his corporate card taken away, the whole office is constantly losing this reward. Do you like this explanation, Angela? I do, actually. It makes sense to me that it would be an incentive. If you reach a certain goal, everyone is Casual Friday. That totally makes sense to me. Yeah.
但因为迈克尔总是惹恼公司，或者公司卡被没收，整个办公室一直在失去这个奖励。你喜欢这个解释吗，安吉拉？我确实喜欢。对我来说，这作为一种激励是有道理的。如果你达到了某个目标，大家就可以享受“休闲星期五”。这对我来说完全说得通。是的。
And I love that she's imagined that Michael is constantly losing Casual Fridays for us. For everyone. Yes. Although I don't think Angela Martin would mind. But I think that actually really would have been a funny runner. Yeah, I do too. Well, you know, lady, there was also a Michael talking head in the shooting draft where he shares a stat
我喜欢她想象迈克尔一直在为我们取消“休闲星期五”。为每个人。是的。虽然我不认为安吉拉·马丁会在意。但我认为那实际上会是一个有趣的连贯笑话。是的，我也这么认为。嗯，你知道，女士，在拍摄草稿中还有一个迈克尔的独白，他分享了一个统计数据，
that he looked up about people missing work on Fridays. We didn't share it in our first breakdown. It's such a Michael classic, I thought I'd read it to you all. So they've just found out that Oscar is missing work because he's not feeling well and it just happens to be a Friday. So Michael says, sick on a Friday, starting the weekend early? Homie, don't play that.
他查了一下关于人们在周五缺勤的情况。我们第一次分析时没有分享它。这太经典了，迈克尔，我想读给你们听。所以他们刚发现奥斯卡因为身体不适没来上班，而那天正好是周五。所以迈克尔说，周五生病，提前开始周末？伙计，别玩这一套。
This is a huge problem in offices everywhere. I looked this up. Two out of every five sick days are taken on a Friday or a Monday. Think about that. Hmm. I bet he's not wrong. I bet that's a real stat. Okay, everyone, that's all we got. Please enjoy your second drink of The Secret.
这是各地办公室的一个大问题。我查过了。每五个病假中就有两个是在周五或周一请的。想想看。嗯。我敢说他没说错。我敢说那是一个真实的统计数据。好了，各位，这就是我们所有的内容了。请享受你们的第二杯“秘密”。
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office Rewatch Podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们将分析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有两个身临其境的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女郎》。
Hi friend. Good morning friend. Today we're talking about the secret. We kind of have a big day today you guys. We have some fun stuff. We have family coming in town, both of us. So I think we're feeling all of that. But we're excited to talk to you about the secret.
嗨，朋友。早上好，朋友。今天我们要谈论“秘密”。伙计们，我们今天有个大日子。我们有一些有趣的事情。我们俩都有家人要来城里。所以我认为我们感受到了这一切。但我们很高兴和你们谈论“秘密”。
Season two, episode 13, written by Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stupnitsky, directed by Denny Gordon. Let's talk a second about Denny Gordon. Denny Gordon is my first fast fact. Let's do it. You hit me with a fast fact, and then I'll add a little color to it. Fast fact number one, directed by Denny Gordon. Denny is a woman.
第二季第13集，由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼茨基编剧，丹妮·戈登执导。让我们花点时间谈谈丹妮·戈登。丹妮·戈登是我的第一个速记事实。开始吧。你给我一个速记事实，然后我会给它加点色彩。速记事实一，由丹妮·戈登执导。丹妮是一位女性。
D-E-N-N-I-E, Gordon. She would go on to direct Boys and Girls. She's also directed several episodes of John Krasinski's show Jack Ryan for Amazon. She's also directed several episodes of John Krasinski's show Jack Ryan for Amazon. She does a lot of dramas. Yeah. Denny was fantastic. She was just a wonderful, delightful person to be around. I have a great
D-E-N-N-I-E，戈登。她后来执导了《男孩和女孩》。她还执导了约翰·卡拉辛斯基为亚马逊制作的剧集《杰克·莱恩》的几集。她还执导了约翰·卡拉辛斯基为亚马逊制作的剧集《杰克·莱恩》的几集。她执导了很多剧情片。是的。丹妮太棒了。她是一个非常美妙、令人愉快的人。我有一张很棒的
photo of all of us, all of us gals gathered around her. We were excited to have another female director. We gathered around her and we have a great picture with her. I often did this though. It wasn't gender specific, you guys. I have photos with us with all the directors. And I do. Yes, you would take photos with the male directors as well. Yeah. They did not discriminate.
照片，我们所有的女孩都围在她身边。我们很高兴有另一位女性导演。我们围在她身边，我们和她有一张很棒的照片。不过我经常这样做。伙计们，这不是性别特定的。我和所有的导演都有合影。我确实有。是的，你也会和男导演合影。是的。他们没有歧视。
I did not discriminate. I have a great picture of me with Harold Ramis, but Denny was just such a delight and I wanted a photo with her. We actually had only six female directors through the nine years of the office. And they were Mindy Kaling, Jen Salata, Amy Heckerling, Claire Scanlon, Kelly Cantley, and Denny Gordon.
我没有歧视。我和哈罗德·雷米斯有一张很棒的照片，但丹妮真是太令人愉快了，我想和她合影。在《办公室》的九年里，我们实际上只有六位女性导演。她们是明迪·卡灵、简·萨拉塔、艾米·海克林、克莱尔·斯坎伦、凯利·坎特利和丹妮·戈登。
So ladies out there directing, we love ya, keep doing it. Let's get some more ladies directing. That's my little speech there. I love it. Denny was and is a trailblazer in terms of female directors. She's been around a really long time. And when researching this episode, I ended up reading a bunch of articles and interviews with her about her experience. Her journey. Yeah, I did too. And it was very inspiring. So guys, Google her. D-E-N-N-I-E Gordon.
所以，在外面的女性导演们，我们爱你们，继续做下去吧。让我们有更多的女性导演。这就是我的小演讲。我喜欢它。丹妮过去是，现在也是女性导演方面的先驱。她已经在这个行业待了很长时间了。在研究这一集时，我最终读了很多关于她的经历和旅程的文章和采访。是的，我也读了。这非常鼓舞人心。所以伙计们，去谷歌搜索她。D-E-N-N-I-E 戈登。
If Denny, if you hear this, we're sending you some love. All right. Where are we at, Jenna? Fast fact number two. We've got a big guest star. We're going to introduce a new recurring character, Tom Chick, who plays Gil. Yes. Oscar's boyfriend. Oscar's love interest. It's a secret. He appeared in four episodes as Oscar's boyfriend, Gil. He also had a recurring role as a reporter on the West Wing. So you might recognize him from that. But here's the crazy thing about him. His big passion in life is video gaming. And he is a very famous video gaming writer. He's written tons of articles, tons of blogs. He's like a video gaming critic.
如果丹妮，如果你听到了这个，我们给你送去一些爱。好了。我们到哪儿了，珍娜？速记事实二。我们有一位大牌客串明星。我们要介绍一位新的常驻角色，汤姆·奇克，他饰演吉尔。是的。奥斯卡的男朋友。奥斯卡的爱慕对象。这是一个秘密。他作为奥斯卡的男朋友吉尔出现了四集。他还在《白宫风云》中饰演过一名记者的常驻角色。所以你可能从那里认出他。但关于他最疯狂的事情是。他生活中最大的热情是电子游戏。他是一位非常有名的电子游戏作家。他写了大量的文章，大量的博客。他就像一位电子游戏评论家。
This is amazing, fascinating. This just proves guys, I always say this, you don't know me. You don't know someone. You have no idea how layered and complex people are. I had no idea. Yeah. Wow, that's cool.
这太神奇了，太迷人了。这证明了伙计们，我总是这么说，你不了解我。你不了解某人。你根本不知道人们是多么有层次和复杂。我完全不知道。是的，太酷了。
All right, are we ready for fast fact number three? Yes. Steve Carell was nominated for a Golden Globe for playing Michael Scott. This was his first nomination for playing Michael Scott the week we shot this episode. and then he won the Golden Globe the week this episode aired. Yes. This was a huge upset shocker win. First of all the fact that he was nominated was insane because he was nominated for those six episodes
好了，准备好速记事实三了吗？是的。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔因饰演迈克尔·斯科特被提名为金球奖。这是他因饰演迈克尔·斯科特获得的第一次提名，就在我们拍摄这一集的那一周。然后他在这一集播出那一周赢得了金球奖。是的。这是一个巨大的冷门惊喜胜利。首先，他被提名这一事实本身就很疯狂，因为他是因为第一季的那六集被提名的。
from season one. You have to remember, we were barely on the air. We were going to get canceled at any minute and we didn't have a lot of clout around town. No. Not at all. So this was like an upset and we were thrilled. It couldn't happen to a nicer person. Steve's acceptance speech is amazing. You can go on YouTube and type in Steve Carell's Golden Globes acceptance speech for 2006.
你必须记住，我们当时几乎没在电视上播出。我们随时都可能被取消，我们在城里没什么影响力。不。一点也没有。所以这就像是一个冷门，我们非常激动。这不可能发生在更好的人身上。史蒂夫的获奖感言太棒了。你可以去YouTube输入“史蒂夫·卡瑞尔2006年金球奖获奖感言”。
He gets up there and he's like, I didn't really know what to say. So my wife, Nancy, wrote my speech. It's one of the best speeches ever. It's so great. And then the whole thank you is from Nancy's perspective. Yes. And it's really funny. Steve was invited to go to the actual ceremony, but the cast, we were invited to a viewing party
他走上去说，我真的不知道该说什么。所以我妻子南希写了我的演讲稿。这是有史以来最好的演讲之一。太棒了。然后整个感谢词都是从南希的角度出发的。是的。而且非常有趣。史蒂夫被邀请参加实际的颁奖典礼，但我们演员被邀请参加一个观看派对，
that was held on a roof of a building. It's actually a parking garage. And it's like the roof of the parking garage, but they tent it. And we're basically across from the hotel. Where the globes are happening. Where the globes are happening. We're sort of like, if you self-parked to stay at this hotel,
在一个建筑的屋顶上举行。实际上是一个停车场。就像停车场的屋顶，但他们搭了帐篷。我们基本上就在酒店对面。金球奖举行的地方。金球奖举行的地方。我们有点像，如果你自己停车住在这家酒店，
we were in the self-park garage building. We are now the only actors on top of a parking garage in a fancy tent with a bunch of people that look like bankers who are very quiet as they watch the show. We are now the rowdy crowd in the corner. Yeah. And Steve's category comes on. They announce him, you know, when they announced his nomination, we're like, woo, yeah, Steve. Go Steve, go Steve. That already raised eyebrows.
我们就在自助停车库大楼里。我们现在是唯一一群在停车场顶上一个豪华帐篷里的演员，和一群看起来像银行家的人在一起，他们看节目时非常安静。我们现在是角落里吵闹的人群。是的。史蒂夫的类别开始了。他们宣布他，你知道，当他们宣布他的提名时，我们就像，呜，耶，史蒂夫。加油史蒂夫，加油史蒂夫。那已经引起了人们的注意。
We already like, woo, Steve. People are already like, what are they doing? So then y'all, he won. Wait, can we reenact what you and I did when they said, and the winner is Steve Carell. Ready? And the winner is Steve Carell. What the?
我们已经像，呜，史蒂夫。人们已经在想，他们在干什么？然后你们看，他赢了。等等，我们可以重演一下当他们说“获奖者是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔”时你和我做了什么吗？准备好了吗？获奖者是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。什么鬼？
Oh my God! Tackle people, hug people, tackle! Have you seen like when a team wins the World Series? It's a Bad News Bears moment. They haven't won in like 50 years. That is what the cast of The Office looked like. We were tackling one another. In our fancy dresses.
天哪！扑倒人，拥抱人，扑倒！你看过球队赢得世界大赛的时候吗？这是一个《少棒闯天下》的时刻。他们已经50年没赢过了。这就是《办公室》演员们看起来的样子。我们互相扑倒。穿着我们的华丽礼服。
In our fancy dresses, running around, whooping it up. I mean, we were insane. Now we have to wait for the whole rest of the show to be over and finally. But we're in full party mode. We're partying it up. I mean, we're having a blast. We're waiting for Steve to come to the party.
穿着我们的华丽礼服，跑来跑去，欢呼雀跃。我的意思是，我们疯了。现在我们必须等待整个节目的其余部分结束，最后。但我们处于完全的派对模式。我们在狂欢。我的意思是，我们玩得很开心。我们在等史蒂夫来参加派对。
Yeah, so here's the thing. When the show ends, everyone, I mean, we're having a blast. We're waiting for Steve to come to the party. Yeah, so here's the thing. When the show ends, everyone, I guess, that's inside where it's being filmed, they file out, and they actually come into the tent where we are. Yeah. And I don't even think we knew that. No. We were like, oh my god.
是的，事情是这样的。当节目结束时，每个人，我的意思是，我们玩得很开心。我们在等史蒂夫来参加派对。是的，事情是这样的。当节目结束时，每个人，我想，在拍摄内部的人，他们走出来，他们实际上来到了我们所在的帐篷。是的。我甚至不认为我们知道这一点。不。我们就像，哦，天哪。
And Steve walked in holding his award. And we tackled him. And then we started posing for group photos with the Golden Globe and Steve. The looks on our faces, we look maniacal. My favorite photo is the photo where Angela had gotten her hand on the Golden Globe. Well, first of all, wait a second. Steve was letting us all hold it. Yeah. And I guess, was it People Magazine?
史蒂夫拿着他的奖杯走了进来。我们扑向了他。然后我们开始和金球奖以及史蒂夫一起拍集体照。我们脸上的表情，我们看起来像疯子。我最喜欢的照片是安吉拉把手放在金球奖上的那张。嗯，首先，等一下。史蒂夫让我们所有人都拿着它。是的。我想，是《人物》杂志吗？
They were taking pictures? There was this little photo booth that you could get into for People Magazine and we shove the entire cast of The Office into this photo booth. Angela's got the Golden Globe and she holds it above her head and goes, woohoo! Yeah, I go, woohoo! Right at the moment that they snapped the picture, and when the picture came back, she is hitting Phyllis in the face with the golden globe. I hit Phyllis in the chin with the golden globe,
他们在拍照？有一个小照相亭，你可以进去为《人物》杂志拍照，我们把《办公室》的所有演员都塞进了这个照相亭。安吉拉拿着金球奖，她把它举过头顶说，呜呼！是的，我说，呜呼！就在他们拍照的那一刻，当照片出来时，她正用金球奖打在菲利斯的脸上。我用金球奖打了菲利斯的下巴，
and the photo actually shows her face contorted like, oh! That's so funny, it's so funny. We have to post it, We have to post that picture. Guys. I'm so sorry I hit you with Steve's Golden Globe. I blame Brian Baumgartner and the just pure happiness for Steve. Here's something really special too. Do you remember when we went back to work the next day at lunch, the catering department served lobster and steak for lunch.
照片实际上显示她的脸扭曲成，哦！太搞笑了，太搞笑了。我们必须发布它，我们必须发布那张照片。伙计们。我很抱歉我用史蒂夫的金球奖打了你。我怪布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳，还有为史蒂夫感到的纯粹快乐。这里还有一些非常特别的事情。你还记得第二天午餐时我们回到工作岗位，餐饮部供应了龙虾和牛排作为午餐吗？
Oh yeah, it was surf and turf to celebrate. It was so decadent and it was really sweet. I know, I remember that and being like, do we have the budget for this? I know, like what can we not do this week because we're eating this? Yeah, all right. Thanks for taking the detour down
哦，是的，那是海陆大餐来庆祝。太奢侈了，真的很贴心。我知道，我记得那个，当时想，我们有这个预算吗？我知道，就像我们这周有什么不能做的吗，因为我们在吃这个？是的，好吧。谢谢你带我绕道走过
the Golden Globes journal entries. Yeah, that was fun for us. We hope that was fun for you. I'm going to hitch up with a summary and then we'll take a break. Okay. So in the Booze Cruise episode, Jim told Michael about his crush on Pam. In this episode, Michael finds out he is the only person who knows the secret and he is delighted in the status that it gives him. So he decides Jim must be his very best friend, that Jim must consider him his best friend
金球奖的日记条目。是的，这对我们来说很有趣。我们希望这对你们来说也很有趣。我要总结一下，然后我们休息一下。好的。在“酒水游轮”那一集里，吉姆告诉迈克尔他暗恋帕姆。在这一集里，迈克尔发现他是唯一知道这个秘密的人，他对自己获得的这种地位感到高兴。所以他决定吉姆一定是他最好的朋友，吉姆一定认为他是他最好的朋友，
since he told him this secret, and he struggles the entire episode to keep the secret to himself. Also in this episode, it is spring cleaning day at the office. Oscar says he can't come to work because of the flu, which causes Dwight to start an investigation into whether or not he's really sick. There it is. That's a good one. And when we come back from the break, we will get into it. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp.
因为他告诉了他这个秘密，他在整集中都在努力保守这个秘密。同样在这一集里，这是办公室的大扫除日。奥斯卡说他因为流感不能来上班，这导致德怀特开始调查他是否真的生病了。就是这样。这是一个很好的情节。当我们从休息回来时，我们将深入探讨它。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。
And this month, BetterHelp is giving you the biggest discount on starting therapy that they have ever offered on our show with 90% off your first week. So here's how it works. With BetterHelp, you can pay a flat fee for weekly sessions and that's going to save you big time on cost and time because therapy should feel accessible. And with online therapy, you get quality care at a price that makes sense. And with over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform and has served over 5 million people globally. And it's convenient. You can join a session with a click of the button and it helps you to fit therapy into your busy life. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge.
这个月，BetterHelp为你提供了他们节目中提供的最大的心理治疗折扣，首周九折。事情是这样的。使用BetterHelp，你可以为每周的课程支付固定费用，这将为你节省大量的时间和金钱，因为心理治疗应该让人感到容易获得。通过在线治疗，你可以以合理的价格获得高质量的护理。拥有超过30,000名治疗师，BetterHelp是世界上最大的在线治疗平台，已在全球服务超过500万人。而且很方便。你可以点击按钮加入会议，它有助于将心理治疗融入你忙碌的生活中。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证治疗师匹配，并可随时免费更换治疗师。
Your wellbeing is worth it. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 90% off your first week. That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. Warning. I've got this condition where I don't feel pain. You're a superhero. No, I'm not.
你的幸福是值得的。今天就访问betterhelp.com/officeladies，首周九折。那是betterhelp，H-E-L-P点com斜杠officeladies。警告。我有一种感觉不到疼痛的病。你是超级英雄。不，我不是。
If this is how intense Novocaine sounds... Oh, wow! ...imagine how it looks. Is there more? Yeah, big time. Novocaine. Forming theaters March 14th. With the Fizz loyalty program, you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan.
如果这就是麻药听起来的强度……哦，哇！……想象一下它看起来是什么样。还有更多吗？是的，非常多。麻药。3月14日影院上映。通过Fizz忠诚度计划，你只需拥有一个移动套餐就能获得奖励。
You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with Fizz. Switch today. Conditions apply, details at fizz.ca. Angela, I think you have a little bit of up dog on your cards. What?
你知道，为了发短信之类的。如果你没有通过你的移动套餐获得像额外数据和美元折扣这样的奖励，你就不是Fizz的用户。今天就切换吧。条件适用，详情请见fizz.ca。安吉拉，我想你的卡片上有一点“Up dog”。什么？
You have some up dog on your cards. What? You have some up dog on your cards. What's up dog? Not much, what's up with you? The cold open of this episode, what's up dog? What's up dog? And Michael is so excited that he's part of this joke and that he gets it and he cannot wait to tell it over and over and it never works.
你的卡片上有一些“Up dog”。什么？你的卡片上有一些“Up dog”。什么是“Up dog”？没什么，你呢？这一集的开场白，什么是“Up dog”？什么是“Up dog”？迈克尔非常兴奋，因为他是这个笑话的一部分，他明白了，他迫不及待地想一遍又一遍地讲它，但它从来都不奏效。
He never gets anyone to ask until the end when Dwight finally says, what's up dog? And he forgets the punchline. He forgets the punchline. And also, I thought it's just one of those moments where Rain is so cute as Dwight where he's sincerely like, oh, thanks for asking. Yeah. Oh, thank you so much. Michael's like, ugh. I reached out to Lee Eisenberg, one of the writers of this episode, and he said that this
直到最后德怀特终于说，什么是“Up dog”？他忘记了笑点。他忘记了笑点。而且，我认为这只是雷恩作为德怀特非常可爱的时刻之一，他真诚地说，哦，谢谢你的询问。是的。哦，非常感谢。迈克尔就像，呃。我联系了这一集的编剧之一李·艾森伯格，他说这个
up dog joke idea happened because this actually happened to those guys. Oh. Yes, they were on the receiving end of an up dog joke that wasn't landing. And they always, that's what writers do. They observe things from their life and they pin it and they're like, I'm gonna put this somewhere one day and it went here. He also reminded me that there was an alternate cold open for this episode. What was it?
“Up dog”笑话的想法是因为这实际上发生在他们身上。哦。是的，他们是“Up dog”笑话的接收方，但没成功。他们总是，这就是编剧所做的。他们观察生活中的事情，并把它们记录下来，他们想，有一天我会把它放在某个地方，它就到了这里。他还提醒我，这一集有一个备用的开场白。是什么？
Michael comes into work and he has purchased a new executive golf set. Yes. And he goes into his office with Dwight and they're trying to use this little putter. And in the process, his world's best boss mug breaks. Yes. And he has a replacement one right away.
迈克尔来上班，他买了一套新的行政高尔夫球具。是的。他和德怀特进了他的办公室，他们试图使用这个小推杆。在这个过程中，他的“世界最佳老板”马克杯碎了。是的。他立刻就有一个替换的。
In his desk. And you can see this in the deleted scenes. And I watched it. But what's fun is later in this episode, you're going to see evidence of this golf set cold open that we replaced with the up dog. I'll keep you waiting. I have time codes and everything. I was going to say, I bet somebody's going to be tracking the golf stuff. I'm going to track it. All right. So after the cold open, the episode begins. It's spring cleaning
在他的桌子里。你可以在删除的场景中看到这一点。我看了。但有趣的是，在这一集后面，你会看到我们用“Up dog”替换掉的这个高尔夫球具开场白的证据。我会让你等着。我有时间码和所有东西。我本来想说，我打赌有人会追踪高尔夫球的东西。我会追踪它的。好了。开场白之后，这一集开始了。这是大扫除
in January. It is. I have a little story about what happens over in the accounting department. Do you want to hear it? I do. Okay. So at one minute 56 seconds, you see Kevin, he's tossing things into the trash, but just like really kind of haphazardly,
在一月。是的。我有一个关于会计部门发生的事情的小故事。你想听吗？我想。好的。在1分56秒，你看到凯文，他把东西扔进垃圾桶，但只是非常随意地，
my character's annoyed, you know, that he's throwing things away. He shouldn't be throwing away. Well, there's a scene that didn't make it. It's an improv scene. It's in the bloopers though. If you go on YouTube and look at season two bloopers, this is where you can find the scene. Kevin then starts digging in the trash because he realized he's thrown away things he probably shouldn't have. And he improvises, I need to go through
我的角色很恼火，你知道，他扔掉了一些他不应该扔掉的东西。嗯，有一个没能放进去的场景。这是一个即兴表演场景。不过它在花絮里。如果你去YouTube看第二季的花絮，这就是你可以找到这个场景的地方。凯文然后开始在垃圾桶里翻找，因为他意识到他扔掉了一些他可能不应该扔掉的东西。他即兴表演，我需要再检查一遍
this again. And then I improvise, but you guys, I sound so Southern when you watch it. This is what I improvise. I do not believe you are engaged. I do not believe it. That is a great improv. That's what I improv. I wish that made it in.
这个。然后我即兴表演，但伙计们，当你看的时候，我听起来太南方了。这就是我即兴表演的。我不相信你订婚了。我不相信。那是一个很棒的即兴表演。这就是我即兴表演的。我希望它能放进去。
What a good dig on Kevin. I know, right? Anyway, it's a really fun little blooper moment and you can find those on YouTube. Also, Kelly is cleaning out magazines. We have half up half down, Jenna. But barely, barely any up. It's like only her little front wispies.
对凯文的挖苦真好。我知道，对吧？无论如何，这是一个非常有趣的即兴花絮时刻，你可以在YouTube上找到它们。此外，凯利正在清理杂志。我们有一半向上，一半向下，珍娜。但几乎没有，几乎没有向上。就像只有她前面的一点点碎发。
I don't know if it's too soon, but I kind of wanna declare that we've hit full Mindy. Full Mindy and personality. That, she still has a little front part up, but still, this is now Mindy. But this updo, this half up half down do is completely different. It's not fussy. It's super stylish. Mm-hmm. Her clothes, I feel like, have really changed in this episode.
我不知道是不是太早了，但我有点想宣布我们已经达到了“完全明迪”。完全明迪的个性和风格。她前面还有一点点向上，但仍然，这现在是明迪了。但这个发型，这个一半向上一半向下的发型完全不同。它不繁琐。它超级时尚。嗯哼。我觉得她的衣服在这一集里真的变了。
Is it? Her personality? Her personality's 100% full Mindy. I wanna declare that it's full Mindy, that the secret is full Mindy. I'm scared to do it cause I feel like there's more to come. I think there's more to come,
是吗？她的个性？她的个性是100%完全明迪。我想宣布它是完全明迪，这个秘密是完全明迪。我不敢这样做，因为我觉得还有更多要来。我想还有更多要来，
but I'm willing to say we're pretty much there. We're 90% full Mindy. We're 90% full Mindy. I'll declare that. We're 90%. 90% full Mindy, the secret. Lee told me also just fun fact, not a fast fact, a fun fact, this is super fun, that
但我愿意说我们差不多到了。我们是90%的完全明迪。我们是90%的完全明迪。我会宣布这一点。我们是90%。90%的完全明迪，秘密。李也告诉我一个有趣的事实，不是速记事实，是一个有趣的事实，这超级有趣，
Lee's friend who works in San Francisco told him about having to do spring cleaning in his office and they put this storyline in at the very last minute. They did not have a lot of turnaround on this episode. Once again, remember last time they told us that they barely got any kind of outline and they had to write their episode. This time, there was a super big rush on the episode. They only had three to four days to write it. Usually, you get a couple of weeks.
李的朋友在旧金山工作，告诉他关于必须在办公室进行大扫除的事情，他们在最后一刻加入了这个故事情节。这一集他们没有太多的周转时间。再一次，记住上次他们告诉我们，他们几乎没有得到任何大纲，他们必须写他们的剧集。这一次，这一集非常匆忙。他们只有三到四天的时间来写它。通常，你有几周的时间。
They had to turn it around really quickly and they needed some storyline for the whole office. They knew the secret storyline between Michael and Jim, and they knew the storyline about Oscar and the investigation about whether or not he was really sick, but they needed something for the rest of us to be doing. So he called Mike Schur and he pitched this idea. My friend told me they had to do spring cleaning at their office. I think I could make it really funny.
他们必须非常快地完成它，他们需要为整个办公室提供一些故事情节。他们知道迈克尔和吉姆之间的秘密故事情节，他们知道关于奥斯卡和关于他是否真的生病的调查的故事情节，但他们需要为我们其他人做点什么。所以他给迈克·舒尔打了电话，他提出了这个想法。我的朋友告诉我，他们必须在办公室进行大扫除。我想我可以让它变得非常有趣。
And he wrote me and he said that Mike Schur's response was, quote, if you have to, you have to. You have to, you have to. If you need it, do it. At two minutes, seven seconds, Jenna, you must have been so tickled. This is like your favorite thing where Michael's talking and then we reveal to other people. Oh, yeah. Not only are you getting a Dwight reveal, but then you get Ryan on the floor.
他写信给我，他说迈克·舒尔的回应是，引用，“如果你必须，你就必须。”如果你必须，你就必须。如果你需要它，就做吧。在2分7秒，珍娜，你一定很开心。这就像你最喜欢的事情，迈克尔在说话，然后我们向其他人揭示。哦，是的。你不仅得到了德怀特的揭示，然后你还得到了在地板上的瑞安。
Yeah. And he said, Michael says, a cluttered desk is a cluttered mind. You guys, my mom, Birdie Kinsey, would say this to me every week. She would say, Angela, a cluttered room is a cluttered mind. Because my room would get messy. When Michael said that, I was like, oh my God, it's my mom. It's my mom. Well, you mentioned the reveal of Ryan sitting on the floor.
是的。他说，迈克尔说，凌乱的桌子就是凌乱的头脑。伙计们，我妈妈，伯迪·金赛，每周都会对我这么说。她会说，安吉拉，凌乱的房间就是凌乱的头脑。因为我的房间会变得很乱。当迈克尔这么说时，我就想，哦，天哪，这是我妈妈。这是我妈妈。嗯，你提到了瑞安坐在地板上的揭示。
There is a deleted scene that explains why he's sitting on the floor. And it is he has two boxes and one says keep and one says trash. And he is sitting on Michael's floor, going through all of Michael's things while Michael reads a newspaper, not cleaning at all. And he's like, this People Magazine from 1994. And Michael's like, keep, keep it.
有一个删除的场景解释了他为什么坐在地板上。那就是他有两个盒子，一个写着“保留”，一个写着“垃圾”。他坐在迈克尔的地板上，翻看迈克尔所有的东西，而迈克尔在读报纸，根本没有打扫。他说，这本1994年的《人物》杂志。迈克尔说，保留，保留它。
He's like, okay. He's like, I might do the crossword. And he's like, it's from 1994. Michael's like, I know, keep. There's nothing in the trash box. It's amazing. It's a fun little, fun little nugget. All right.
他说，好的。他说，我可能会做填字游戏。他说，这是1994年的。迈克尔说，我知道，保留。垃圾箱里什么都没有。太神奇了。这是一个有趣的小片段。好了。
I need to talk about two minutes, 34 seconds, the very, very long stare between Dwight and Angela. Yeah. Dwangela. Yeah. I have a fan question from Where Are the Turtles? The long stare with Dwight and Angela is so brilliant as are future stares. Is it hard to not crack up while filming those? Angela, tell us all about it. Yeah, it's hard not to crack up. I'm sure there's tons of footage of me getting tickled. And also it was so fun. It is so fun. One thing I think we do in society is like we know not to stare. We grow up, right? And our
我需要谈谈2分34秒，德怀特和安吉拉之间非常、非常长的凝视。是的。德怀特和安吉拉。是的。我有一个粉丝问题来自“乌龟在哪里？”。德怀特和安吉拉的长凝视太精彩了，未来的凝视也是如此。拍摄这些的时候不笑场很难吗？安吉拉，告诉我们这一切。是的，很难不笑场。我相信有大量的镜头是我被逗乐的。而且这也太有趣了。这太有趣了。我认为我们在社会中做的一件事是，我们知道不要盯着看。我们长大了，对吧？我们的
parents are like, don't stare, don't stare. And so all of a sudden you're given permission to just stare at someone and draw it out as long as possible. There were times when I thought the director was going to yell cut, because I'm like, surely they're done watching us stare at each other. And they're like, no, keep it going. It was really fun. But yeah, very hard to keep a straight face. And of course, having Kevin there watching us,
父母说，不要盯着看，不要盯着看。所以突然间你被允许盯着某人看，并尽可能地把它拉长。有几次我以为导演要喊停，因为我想，他们肯定看够了我们互相盯着看。他们说，不，继续。这真的很有趣。但是的，很难保持严肃的表情。当然，有凯文在那里看着我们，
what are you doing? Well, some context, too, to the scene is that he comes up and says that Oscar is out sick and says something like, that's unacceptable. And you say, I agree, it's unacceptable. And there is like some charged, like you both are very aroused by your agreement that this is unacceptable.
你在干什么？嗯，这个场景的一些背景是，他走过来，说奥斯卡生病了，说了一些类似“这是不可接受的”的话。你说，我同意，这是不可接受的。你们俩都因为你们同意这是不可接受的而感到非常兴奋。
Oh no, I put, we get really turned on by unacceptable behavior. Exactly. Exactly. Exactly. Jenna, I have something to point out, my lady friend. What is it? At two minutes, 50 seconds, when Dwight says Oscar is out sick,
哦，不，我放了，我们对不可接受的行为感到非常兴奋。完全正确。完全正确。完全正确。珍娜，我有一件事要指出，我的女士朋友。是什么？在2分50秒，当德怀特说奥斯卡生病了，
Michael says, and on a Friday? It's Friday! Again a Friday and no one is dressed casually. Uh huh. Thank you for catching that. Yeah. I don't even know what to do with that. I don't even know what to say about it.
迈克尔说，而且是在周五？是周五！又是一个周五，没有人穿休闲装。嗯哼。谢谢你注意到这一点。是的。我甚至不知道该怎么处理它。我甚至不知道该说什么。
I don't know what to do with it. I don't know what to say about it. Four minutes, nine seconds, Pam and Kelly. Pam is planning her wedding. Kelly asks to be a bridesmaid. That is hilarious. I love that so much. Who has the audacity?
我不知道该怎么处理它。我不知道该说什么。4分9秒，帕姆和凯利。帕姆正在计划她的婚礼。凯利要求当伴娘。这太搞笑了。我非常喜欢那个。谁有这种胆量？
Not even a really good friend to be like, oh my God, can I be in your wedding? She's like, you don't have to answer now. There's also so much going on in the scene because Pam takes her hair down and she floofs it out. You can see Jim in the background over Kelly's shoulder. Poor Jim is what I wrote. Poor Jim. Poor Jim.
甚至不是一个真正的好朋友，就说，哦，天哪，我可以参加你的婚礼吗？她说，你现在不必回答。场景中还有很多事情发生，因为帕姆把头发放下来，她把它弄蓬松了。你可以看到吉姆在凯利肩膀后面的背景里。可怜的吉姆是我写的。可怜的吉姆。可怜的吉姆。
And then, you know, Michael comes out of his office and has to make a comment. This was a tricky one to film and I always want to point these scenes out because I just think they're really great examples of the choreography of our director, our camera operators. It's really something special to capture this stuff. Well, Michael says you should leave your hair down more because it's sexier. And then he walks past Jim and he goes, oh, this must be so hard on you.
然后，你知道，迈克尔从他的办公室出来，必须发表评论。这是一个很难拍摄的场景，我总是想指出这些场景，因为我认为它们是我们导演、摄像师编排的非常好的例子。捕捉这些东西真的很特别。嗯，迈克尔说你应该多把头发放下来，因为它更性感。然后他走过吉姆，他说，哦，这对你来说一定很难。
Yeah. Way to make it all worse, Michael. Then we move on to a spy shot conversation between Jim and Michael in Michael's office. This is when Michael finds out that he is the only person who knows about Jim's feelings for Pam. And I want you to notice that four minutes 57 seconds, Michael is playing with a golf ball.
是的。迈克尔，真会把事情弄得更糟。然后我们继续进行吉姆和迈克尔在迈克尔办公室里的间谍谈话。这是迈克尔发现他是唯一知道吉姆对帕姆感情的人的时候。我想让你注意4分57秒，迈克尔在玩高尔夫球。
Oh yes, he is. And that is because of that cold open that we cut out. Right, and he had all the golf stuff in his office. Yeah. Right, well, Michael says something in this scene that I thought was so great. It's his talking head, and Steve is so brilliant in it. He just talks about how special it is,
哦，是的，他是。那是因为我们剪掉的那个开场白。对，他办公室里有所有的高尔夫球东西。是的。好吧，迈克尔在这一幕中说了一些我觉得非常棒的话。这是他的独白，史蒂夫在里面太精彩了。他只是谈论分享是多么特别，
obviously, that Jim shared with him, and what good friends they are, blah, blah, blah. But his last sentence just made me laugh. He goes, and it is why I intend on keeping that secret for as long as I possibly can. He totally owns that he sucks at keeping a secret. You guys, my dad was someone who absolutely could not hold onto information.
显然，吉姆和他分享了，他们是多么好的朋友，等等，等等。但他最后一句让我笑了。他说，这就是为什么我打算尽可能长时间地保守这个秘密。他完全承认他保守秘密很烂。伙计们，我爸爸是一个绝对无法保守信息的人。
Now he was a wonderful friend and father and confidant, all of those things. But if there was like some great information, there was no way he could not like tell you or it just it would be all over his face. Yeah, I had no poker face. When Steve said that I just sort of chuckled and thought of my dad and how hard it was for him to like, keep any news from us. Are you good with secrets? Are you more like your dad? I think I'm good. I think I'm good. I don't know, Jenna, you've known me a long time.
现在他是一个很棒的朋友、父亲和知己，所有这些事情。但如果有什么伟大的信息，他根本不可能不告诉你，或者它只会写在他的脸上。是的，我没有扑克脸。当史蒂夫这么说时，我只是轻声笑了笑，想到了我爸爸，以及他保守任何消息不告诉我们是多么困难。你擅长保守秘密吗？你更像你爸爸吗？我想我擅长。我想我擅长。我不知道，珍娜，你认识我很久了。
I think you're good. Yeah. We had a fan question, actually. It was Shanice who asked, are you too good at keeping secrets? Do you have that one person that you just have to share it with because you trust them and that's OK? Yeah.
我想你很擅长。是的。我们实际上有一个粉丝问题。是沙妮丝问的，你们两个擅长保守秘密吗？你有没有那个你必须分享的人，因为你信任他们，那没关系？是的。
Well, anyone who tells me anything should know that I'm gonna tell Jenna I Am unless you like if you're like, hey, you can't say this to anyone Yeah, okay, and then I'm gonna tell my husband I tell my husband everything like you have to really say. All right You can't and then I probably will at some point tell you or my so even I might sit on it for a bit. But eventually, I mean, I honestly,
嗯，任何告诉我任何事情的人都应该知道，我会告诉珍娜，除非你像，嘿，你不能告诉任何人。是的，好的，然后我会告诉我的丈夫。我告诉我的丈夫所有事情，就像你必须真正说出来一样。好的。你不能，然后我可能会在某个时候告诉你或我的，所以我甚至可能会坐一会儿。但最终，我的意思是，我老实说，
I'm sitting here thinking like, I don't know, Jenna, that I pretty much have to download everything to you. It's like kind of how I process information. I receive information. I know how I feel about it. But then it either becomes more real or more clear to me once I share it with you or Josh. I feel the same way.
我坐在这里想，我不知道，珍娜，我几乎必须把一切都下载给你。这就像我处理信息的方式。我接收信息。我知道我对它的感觉。但一旦我与你或乔什分享，它要么变得更真实，要么对我更清晰。我也感觉一样。
You and Lee are the two people that I tell everything to. So if someone tells me something in confidence, I assume they know that they're telling me, Angela and Lee simultaneously. My best friend and my husband. That's right. However, I will say there are things that you have told me, Angela, that I have not shared with Lee and there are things that Lee has told me that I've not shared with you.
你和李是我告诉一切的两个人。所以如果有人私下告诉我什么，我假设他们知道他们是在同时告诉我和安吉拉。我最好的朋友和我的丈夫。没错。然而，我会说有些事情是你告诉我的，安吉拉，我没有告诉李，有些事情是李告诉我的，我没有告诉过你。
Same. So I do. Those two people are like, they get special treatment. Yes, that's right. All the rest of y'all just know I'm blabbing to Lee and Angela if you told me. Yeah. Unless you specifically tell me not to and then similar to you, Angela, I will sit on it for a bit and then tell them anyway.
一样。所以我确实。那两个人就像，他们得到了特殊待遇。是的，没错。你们所有其他人只知道如果你告诉了我，我就会向李和安吉拉泄密。是的。除非你特别告诉我不要，然后类似于你，安吉拉，我会坐一会儿，然后无论如何都会告诉他们。
Oh yeah. At five minutes, 43 seconds, Dwight goes up to Ryan and he wants Ryan basically to take over the spring cleaning stuff because he's got this investigation to conduct. Now I did a ton of scenes with Rainn Wilson, and Rainn loves a prop. And once he gets a prop, he's very attached to a prop. So he did this thing in this scene that made me laugh so hard. He walks up to Ryan, he has his little notepad he's writing in. Yeah.
哦，是的。在5分43秒，德怀特走到瑞安面前，他基本上想让瑞安接管大扫除的事情，因为他有这个调查要进行。现在我和雷恩·威尔逊拍了很多场景，雷恩喜欢道具。一旦他得到一个道具，他就会非常依恋一个道具。所以他在这一幕中做了一件事，让我笑得太厉害了。他走到瑞安面前，他有他的小笔记本，他在上面写字。是的。
And as he walks up to Ryan, he takes it out of his jacket pocket and he flashes it at Ryan as if it's like a badge. You have to wash it. It's this very subtle move. It's just a notepad. It looks like one of those notepads that you win for 200 tickets at Chuck E. Cheese. Exactly. Yeah.
当他走向瑞安时，他从夹克口袋里掏出它，像展示徽章一样在瑞安面前晃了晃。你得把它洗洗。这是一个非常微妙的动作。那只是个记事本。看起来就像你在查克芝士餐厅花200张奖券赢来的那种记事本。没错。是的。
Exactly. So he's like, I'm conducting a little investigation. He flashes the notepad. Like that is going to be like, oh, okay. This is legit. Yeah. To Ryan. And Ryan, of course, is just like, ugh.
没错。所以他就像是说，我正在进行一个小调查。他晃了晃记事本。好像这样就能让人觉得，哦，好吧。这是合法的。是的。对瑞安来说。而瑞安，当然，只是觉得，呃。
So then we move to the vending machines. Michael is trying to talk to Jim more about his love of Pam at the vending machines and Stanley enters. Oh, gosh. And Stanley is taking forever to pick a beverage. He is. Just forever. And he's in the way. And Michael is trying so much to capitalize on this bonding time with Jim. Yeah. He's like, we're best friends.
接着我们转到自动售货机那边。迈克尔正试图在自动售货机旁和吉姆多聊聊他爱上帕姆的事，这时斯坦利进来了。哦，天哪。斯坦利选饮料选了半天。确实。就是半天。而且他挡路了。迈克尔非常想利用这段和吉姆增进感情的时间。是的。他就像是说，我们是最好的朋友。
We share secrets. I want I just want to spend now as much time as possible with him. I want to chat about his love for him. I want him to know I'm a great friend. At the end of that scene, Michael just picks an item for Stanley, and it's peach iced tea. And then Steve says, you're going to hate it. That was improvised.
我们分享秘密。我只想现在尽可能多花点时间和他在一起。我想聊聊他爱上帕姆的事。我想让他知道我是一个好朋友。在那场戏的最后，迈克尔直接帮斯坦利选了一样东西，是桃子冰茶。然后史蒂夫说，你会讨厌它的。那是即兴发挥的。
And that was a moment that a lot of people wrote in about when I asked, what do you want us to talk about for this moment was the peach iced tea. You're going to hate it. And it was an improvised moment. It was so great. And also in that scene, John could not stop laughing. He could not stop laughing this whole episode. He had to spend a lot of time with Steve doing scenes and John really loses it. So this was one of those scenes. John, when he loses it, his whole body collapses. He just becomes a noodle. At 6 minutes 58 seconds, my background observers out there, I need your help. Dwight is calling Oscar again. Poor Oscar. Dwight's just like calling him like crazy. But as he's sitting on his desk, he's on the phone, behind him.
那是一个很多人写信来问的时刻，当我问大家想让我们聊聊哪个片段时，大家提到了桃子冰茶。你会讨厌它的。那是一个即兴的时刻。太棒了。而且在那场戏里，约翰笑得停不下来。他这一整集都笑个不停。他不得不花很多时间和史蒂夫演对手戏，约翰真的控制不住。所以这是其中一场戏。约翰一旦笑场，整个人就会瘫掉。他就像变成了一根面条。在6分58秒，各位背景观察员，我需要你们的帮助。德怀特又在给奥斯卡打电话了。可怜的奥斯卡。德怀特简直像疯了一样给他打电话。但当他坐在办公桌前打电话时，在他身后。
OK, so the hand that's holding the phone. Look at the hand holding the phone. Look behind his hand. It's like a file cabinet next to Phyllis's desk. There is a hairy object. It's a black, hairy object. What is it? Look, wait, Sam, can you pull up six minutes, 58 seconds?
好的，拿着电话的那只手。看看那只拿着电话的手。看看他手后面。那是菲利斯桌子旁边的文件柜。有一个毛茸茸的东西。那是一个黑色的、毛茸茸的东西。那是什么？看，等等，萨姆，你能调到6分58秒吗？
I kind of need Jenna to see it. There it is, you got it, look at it. What, I see nothing, what are you talking about? Oh, what is that? What is that? It looks like a wig on a wig stand. I know, on the fall cabinet next to us. I'm gonna get up and I'm gonna physically look closer.
我需要珍娜看看。就在那儿，看到了吧，看看它。什么，我什么都没看见，你在说什么？哦，那是什么？那是什么？看起来像假发架上的假发。我知道，就在我们旁边的文件柜上。我要站起来，我要亲自去近距离看看。
Okay, we've looked at it and Jenna said she- I know what it is and look at what Cody is holding in the booth, look through the window. Do you see Cody? Cody's our producer. Yeah, what is that thing? A feather duster. Stop it, are you sure?
好了，我们看过了，珍娜说她——我知道那是什么，看看科迪在隔间里拿着什么，透过窗户看。你看到科迪了吗？科迪是我们的制片人。是的，那是什么东西？鸡毛掸子。别闹了，你确定吗？
Feather duster. Really? Yeah. I think Phyllis has a feather duster as part of her spring cleaning and I think that's what it is. Oh, that's a good call. And also, Cody, where the heck are you?
鸡毛掸子。真的吗？是的。我想菲利斯可能在春季大扫除时用到了鸡毛掸子，我想那就是它。哦，这个推测不错。还有，科迪，你到底在哪儿？
Yeah, Cody, where did you get a feather duster just now? How is it just like, you're like, oh, wait a second. It's like, it's like your carrot top and you have a trunk full of random props. Guys, Cody is a little bit like me. I think she's very organized and structured and I believe she might walk around with a feather duster. Well, we've never seen it before. Where's she keeping it? Oh my God. All right. Sorry, sorry to take us down that road, but that was making me crazy last night. At seven minutes, 34 seconds. Again, Michael desperate to connect more with Jim. He's so excited about having a friend. He's following him around like a little puppy. He is. And he walks up to him and he goes, it's grape soda.
是啊，科迪，你刚才从哪儿弄来的鸡毛掸子？你怎么会，就像是，你等一下。这就像是，这就像你的卡罗特·托普（Carrot Top），你的后备箱里装满了各种随机道具。伙计们，科迪有点像我。我觉得她非常有条理、有规划，我相信她可能真的会随身带着鸡毛掸子。好吧，我们以前从没见过。她把它藏哪儿了？天哪。好了。抱歉，抱歉带大家跑题了，但昨晚这事儿让我快疯了。在7分34秒。迈克尔再次迫切地想和吉姆拉近关系。他为有了个朋友而感到非常兴奋。他像只小狗一样跟着他。确实。他走到他身边说，是葡萄汽水。
Because he got a grape soda too, because Jim got a grape soda. So adorable. In this section, Dwight approaches and asks what's going on. And then Jim keeps putting Post-It notes on Dwight. And fan question from Tabitha, was the Post-It notes on Dwight improvised? I believe it was.
因为他也买了一瓶葡萄汽水，因为吉姆买了葡萄汽水。太可爱了。在这一段，德怀特走过来问发生了什么事。然后吉姆不停地往德怀特身上贴便利贴。来自塔比莎的粉丝提问，德怀特身上的便利贴是即兴发挥的吗？我相信是的。
I think that was John. It's so perfect though. It is so perfectly their relationship. And then Rain, you know, as Dwight would like try to stick it back on him. Yeah. It was just perfect. Yes.
我觉得那是约翰的主意。不过太完美了。这简直完美地体现了他们的关系。然后雷恩，你知道，德怀特会试图把它贴回他身上。是的。这简直太完美了。是的。
At eight minutes, 46 seconds, Steve puts his leg up on Jim's desk. He puts his foot on top of his desk and leans forward. Like leans really, really his crotch. Into Jim's face. And John lost it. I was there that day filming. John could not stop laughing.
在8分46秒，史蒂夫把腿架在吉姆的桌子上。他把脚放在桌面上，身体前倾。就像是把他的胯部，真的，非常用力地。凑到吉姆的脸上。约翰笑场了。那天拍摄时我就在现场。约翰笑得停不下来。
Very similar to diversity day, Angela, when you and I were in the conference room and Steve straddled the chair. And leaned forward to us. Yeah, really. And part of it too was that that desk is really high and it was not super easy for Steve to put his leg up there. And his dress pants.
和“多元化日”那集很像，安吉拉，当时你和我在会议室里，史蒂夫跨坐在椅子上。然后向我们前倾。是的，真的。部分原因也是因为那张桌子很高，史蒂夫要把腿架上去并不容易。而且他还穿着西裤。
But he was super committed to the bit. It was something he just came up with and it made John laugh. So then he kept doing it. But I think it was like, that was not easy. No, the desk is really high. You have to be very flexible to pull that off. So kudos to you, Steve, for being so committed to that bit. Well, I wrote about this as well.
但他非常投入这个梗。这是他临时想出来的，而且让约翰笑了。所以他就一直这么做。但我认为这就像是，这并不容易。不，桌子很高。你得非常灵活才能做到这一点。所以向你致敬，史蒂夫，为了对这个梗如此投入。好吧，我也写过这个。
And I said that, you guys, Steve always found ways, as Michael, to put his feet up on things or just really sort of push a physical comfort zone that you have with another person. He always thought that was like sort of as Michael, a really funny gimmick and it got us every time. I just think at 8 minutes 55 seconds, it's just kind of funny to me that Kevin is just walking over to front reception and just setting boxes down in front of Pam. I know. Thanks. What am I doing with those down in front of Pam. I know, thanks.
我说过，你们知道，史蒂夫总是能找到方法，作为迈克尔，把脚架在东西上，或者真的去挑战你和另一个人之间的身体舒适区。他总是认为作为迈克尔，这是一个非常有趣的噱头，而且每次都让我们中招。我只是觉得在8分55秒，凯文走到前台，把盒子放在帕姆面前，这对我来说有点好笑。我知道。谢谢。我把那些东西放在帕姆面前干什么。我知道，谢谢。
What am I doing with those? I don't know. I guess that's my problem now. What is Kevin doing? So next guys, Michael decides to take Jim out to lunch. Well, Jim is just trying to get him out of the office so he doesn't spill the beans in front of Pam. So I don't think Jim would ever want to go out to lunch
我拿着那些东西干什么？我不知道。我想现在那是我的问题了。凯文在干什么？所以接下来，伙计们，迈克尔决定带吉姆出去吃午饭。好吧，吉姆只是想把他带离办公室，这样他就不会在帕姆面前说漏嘴。所以我认为吉姆根本不想出去吃午饭
with Michael, especially to where he takes him. Hooters. Hooters. They go to Hooters. I have so many feelings about it, Angela. I know you do, honey. When I was watching it, guys, I'm not going to lie to you, not a fan of the restaurants of this nature.
和迈克尔一起，尤其是去他带他去的地方。猫头鹰餐厅（Hooters）。猫头鹰餐厅。他们去了猫头鹰餐厅。安吉拉，我对此有很多感触。我知道你有，亲爱的。当我在看这一集时，伙计们，我不撒谎，我不是这种餐厅的粉丝。
Well, did you read their origin story? It was like when five, I'm paraphrasing guys. I did I went to the Hooters website. I had to spend a lot of time on the Hooters website. Yeah, more time than I wish I did. Well, it's something like when a group of five guys who kept getting kicked out of places decided to they wanted, you know, pretty girls and hot wings. So anyway, listen, for y'all folks out there that enjoy Hooters, that's for you. That's for you. Okay. Okay.
好吧，你读过他们的起源故事吗？就像是当五个，伙计们，我是在转述。我确实去了猫头鹰餐厅的网站。我不得不在猫头鹰餐厅的网站上花了很多时间。是的，比我希望的时间要多。好吧，大概是说，当五个总是被赶出来的家伙决定他们想要，你知道，漂亮的女孩和辣鸡翅。所以无论如何，听着，对于你们这些喜欢猫头鹰餐厅的人来说，那是给你们的。那是给你们的。好的。好的。
Anyway, we did have a fan question from Rob M. Did you shoot in a real Hooters and were they real Hooters waitresses? Yes, we filmed in a real Hooters waitresses. Yes, we filmed in a real Hooters and yes, they were real Hooters waitresses except for the main waitress, Dana. She was played by an actress. That's right. Dana is played by Lindsay Stoddard, who is a really funny actress writer, improviser. I knew her back in my IO days, Improv Olympic days. And this Hooters in particular was in Burbank that they filmed in. It is now closed. It's out of business. So you can't go there. Not shedding tears. And of course Michael had to say
总之，我们确实有一个来自罗伯·M的粉丝提问。你们是在真正的猫头鹰餐厅拍摄的吗？她们是真正的猫头鹰餐厅女服务员吗？是的，我们在真正的猫头鹰餐厅拍摄的。是的，我们是在真正的猫头鹰餐厅拍摄的，是的，她们是真正的猫头鹰餐厅女服务员，除了主要的女服务员达娜。她是由一位女演员扮演的。没错。达娜由琳赛·斯托达德扮演，她是一位非常有趣的演员、编剧和即兴表演者。我在我的IO时期，即兴奥林匹克时期就认识她了。而且这家猫头鹰餐厅特别是在伯班克拍摄的。它现在已经关门了。倒闭了。所以你不能去那儿了。没流眼泪。当然迈克尔不得不说
chicken breasts, hold the chicken. Yeah. That's a classic moment. But I love Dana's response, which is, is that really what you want? Yeah. And he's like, no gourmet hot dog. But let me say something. Jim orders a ham and cheese. Michael orders a gourmet hot dog. But let me say something. Jim orders a ham and cheese. Michael orders a gourmet hot dog. I could not find either of these items on the online Hooters menu. I couldn't. I don't know. Guys, anyone who's gone to Hooters, do they serve ham and cheese and or a gourmet hot dog? I would actually love to know. Do you know what I noticed? I noticed the girls look like they have to wear pantyhose under their shorts. Yes, they do. And I did a deep dive on Hooters. They do. They do wear pantyhose.
鸡胸肉，不要鸡肉。是的。那是经典时刻。但我喜欢达娜的回答，那是，你真的想要那个吗？是的。他说，不，美食热狗。但让我说点什么。吉姆点了火腿奶酪三明治。迈克尔点了美食热狗。但让我说点什么。吉姆点了火腿奶酪三明治。迈克尔点了美食热狗。我在猫头鹰餐厅的在线菜单上找不到这两样东西。我找不到。我不知道。伙计们，任何去过猫头鹰餐厅的人，他们供应火腿奶酪三明治和/或美食热狗吗？我真的很想知道。你知道我注意到了什么吗？我注意到女孩们看起来好像必须在短裤下穿连裤袜。是的，她们必须穿。我深入研究了猫头鹰餐厅。她们确实穿。她们确实穿连裤袜。
That would listen. I would be for I would I like that. I like it that it's not their bare leg. So I do appreciate that there's that. I just don't like pantyhose. So. Well, we know, we know, guys, if, Angela might have worked at a Hooters, but the pantyhose thing. I'm fine with the tank top, but you lost me at the pantyhose. Fan comment from Rick Wilson, he pointed out that there is no Hooters in Scranton. There are not any Hooters in Scranton.
那听着。我会支持，我喜欢那个。我喜欢它不是她们裸露的腿。所以我确实很欣赏这一点。我只是不喜欢连裤袜。所以。好吧，我们知道，我们知道，伙计们，如果安吉拉可能在猫头鹰餐厅工作过，但连裤袜那件事。我能接受背心，但连裤袜让我无法接受。来自里克·威尔逊的粉丝评论，他指出斯克兰顿没有猫头鹰餐厅。斯克兰顿没有任何猫头鹰餐厅。
I googled it. It's true. I googled it as well. There are two Hooters in Pennsylvania, one in Concordville and one in King of Prussia. Okay. So that's where you can go. Fan question from Ryan Ritter. Is it true that the Hooters girls singing the happy birthday song was an added bit? No, this was scripted. You put your front side in, you put your front side out. Okay, here's the thing. This seems like an old birthday tradition. At Hooters?
我谷歌了一下。是真的。我也谷歌了一下。宾夕法尼亚州有两家猫头鹰餐厅，一家在康科德维尔，一家在普鲁士国王市。好的。所以那是你可以去的地方。来自瑞安·里特的粉丝提问。猫头鹰餐厅的女孩们唱生日快乐歌是一个加进去的梗是真的吗？不，这是有剧本的。你把你的前侧放进去，你把你的前侧拿出来。好的，事情是这样的。这看起来像是一个古老的生日传统。在猫头鹰餐厅？
At Hooters. Okay. And it didn't, they don't say put your front side in. The real song is put your hooters in, put your hooters out. And then they put, and then they shake them all about. They get in a circle around the birthday boy. And shake their tatas at them.
在猫头鹰餐厅。好的。而且它没有，她们不说把你的前侧放进去。真正的歌是把你的猫头鹰放进去，把你的猫头鹰拿出来。然后她们放，然后她们摇晃它们。她们围着寿星转圈。并向他们摇晃她们的胸部。
Right. And then they put their backside in, put their backside out, and shake that all about. That's their butt? That's right, Angela, yes. That's their butt. So it's sort of like an inappropriate hokey pokey. Correct. And shake that all about. That's their butt? That's right, Angela. Yes, that's their butt. So it's sort of like an inappropriate hokey pokey.
对。然后她们把她们的后侧放进去，把她们的后侧拿出来，然后摇晃它们。那是她们的屁股？没错，安吉拉，是的。那是她们的屁股。所以这有点像是不恰当的“哈基波基”舞。正确。然后摇晃它们。那是她们的屁股？没错，安吉拉。是的，那是她们的屁股。所以这有点像是不恰当的“哈基波基”舞。
Correct. Okay. But that seems to be the old birthday policy. Although I did find a video from as recent as 2015 where they were still doing this down in Georgia. But the main birthday song is where now they dress you up like an owl. Okay. They give you a beak and they give you some menus and you have to flap your wings and
正确。好的。但这似乎是旧的生日政策。虽然我确实发现了一个2015年的视频，她们在佐治亚州还在这样做。但主要的生日歌是现在她们把你打扮成猫头鹰。好的。她们给你一个喙，给你一些菜单，你必须拍打你的翅膀，然后
then all the Hooters girls like sing that it's your birthday, it's your birthday today, birthday sort of like that. I have one fan question that I forgot to cover from Ben Shown. Does John actually like ham and cheese sandwiches? Guys, I texted John. Oh, random text. By the way, you're on a real roll. You texted Steve about what was it?
所有的猫头鹰餐厅女孩唱着今天是你的生日，今天是你的生日，生日之类的。我有一个忘记回答的来自本·肖恩的粉丝提问。约翰真的喜欢火腿奶酪三明治吗？伙计们，我给约翰发了短信。哦，随机短信。顺便说一句，你真的很厉害。你给史蒂夫发短信问的是什么？
Something so random. If he had a fake foot in the injury. Yeah. And now you're like, John, do you really like ham and cheese? We're going to start alienating people. John wrote me back and said he does, especially when the bread is toasted. Okay. There you go.
一些非常随机的事情。如果他在受伤时有假脚。是的。现在你又问，约翰，你真的喜欢火腿奶酪吗？我们要开始疏远人们了。约翰回信说他喜欢，尤其是当面包烤过的时候。好的。就是这样。
There you go. I have something at 10 minutes, 14 seconds. It is Rain, as Dwight, eating only the black jelly beans. Yeah. Or like the purple ones. I mean, was that in the script? It seems like something Rain would do because he likes to kind of be gross. It was in the script and he had to chew a bunch of them before we started and kind of stick the half bits up into his teeth. We had a fan question from Janelle, does Rain actually like black jelly
就是这样。我在10分14秒有一个发现。是雷恩，作为德怀特，只吃黑色的软糖豆。是的。或者紫色的那些。我的意思是，那在剧本里吗？这看起来像是雷恩会做的事情，因为他喜欢有点恶心。这在剧本里，他在我们开始之前不得不嚼了一堆，并把半块塞进他的牙齿里。我们有一个来自珍妮尔的粉丝提问，雷恩真的喜欢黑色的软糖
beans? Tell me you didn't text him. I texted him. Oh no. Oh my God. And he does. Oh, well, that's a relief. That's a relief. I have a question for you. In this scene, I guess Dwight tells you there's three ways to sniffle. Yeah.
豆吗？告诉我你没给他发短信。我给他发了短信。哦，不。天哪。而且他喜欢。哦，好吧，那真是松了一口气。那真是松了一口气。我有一个问题要问你。在这场戏里，我猜德怀特告诉你吸鼻涕有三种方式。是的。
Because he's trying to figure out if Oscar is lying, right? Yeah, and I said, he sounded like he was telling the truth. I mean, he was sniffling when he called. And then he's like, what type of sniffle? And you're like, are there types? And he's like, there are three types of sniffles. And then Pam says it was the second one. Yeah.
因为他想弄清楚奥斯卡是否在撒谎，对吧？是的，我说，他听起来像是在说实话。我的意思是，他打电话时在吸鼻涕。然后他说，哪种吸鼻涕？你说，还有种类吗？他说，有三种吸鼻涕。然后帕姆说是第二种。是的。
And Dwight's like, okay. He's like, was that so hard? But also he does, you say it was the second one as if he has told you what the three of them are. I think that's amazing writing. Oh my gosh. It's amazing writing. All right.
德怀特说，好的。他说，这很难吗？但他也确实，你说那是第二种，就好像他已经告诉你那三种是什么一样。我觉得这剧本写得太棒了。哦，天哪。这剧本写得太棒了。好了。
Should we go to break? Let's go to break. When the frustration grows and the doubts start to creep in, we all need someone who has our back to tell us we'll be okay, to remind us of our ability to believe, because their belief in us transfers to self-belief and reminds us of all that we're capable of. We all need someone to make us believe. Hashtag, you got this. This episode is brought to you by Samsung Galaxy. Ever captured a great night video only for it to be ruined by that one noisy talker?
我们要去休息一下吗？我们去休息一下吧。当挫折感增加，怀疑开始潜入时，我们都需要一个支持我们的人告诉我们一切都会好起来，提醒我们相信自己的能力，因为他们对我们的信念会转化为自信，并提醒我们我们所能做的一切。我们都需要有人让我们相信。标签，你能行的。本集由三星Galaxy赞助。有没有捕捉到一段很棒的夜间视频，却被那个吵闹的说话者毁了？
With audio erase on the new Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra, you can reduce or remove unwanted noise and relive your favorite moments without the distractions. And that's not all. New Galaxy AI features like NowBrief will give you personalized insights based on your day schedule so that you're prepared no matter what. New Galaxy AI features like NowBrief will give you personalized insights based on your day's schedule so that you're prepared no matter what. Buy the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra now at Samsung.com. Hit pause on whatever you're listening to and hit play on your next adventure.
有了新款三星Galaxy S25 Ultra上的音频擦除功能，你可以减少或消除不需要的噪音，重温你最喜欢的时刻，而不会受到干扰。还不止这些。新的Galaxy AI功能，如NowBrief，将根据你的日程安排为你提供个性化的见解，让你无论发生什么都能做好准备。新的Galaxy AI功能，如NowBrief，将根据你的日程安排为你提供个性化的见解，让你无论发生什么都能做好准备。立即在Samsung.com购买三星Galaxy S25 Ultra。暂停你正在听的任何内容，开始你的下一次冒险。
Stay two nights and get a $50 Best Western gift card. Life's the trip. Make the most of it at Best Western. Visit BestWestern.com for complete terms and conditions. Okay, so we are back from break. And on break, you guys, I was talking a little bit of Game of Thrones with Sam. Because Angela loves to just alienate and torture me. No, and I mentioned Khaleesi. Tell them what you said.
住两晚，获得一张50美元的Best Western礼品卡。生活就是一场旅行。在Best Western充分利用它。访问BestWestern.com了解完整的条款和条件。好的，我们休息回来了。在休息时，伙计们，我正在和萨姆聊一点《权力的游戏》。因为安吉拉喜欢疏远和折磨我。不，我提到了卡丽熙。告诉他们你说了什么。
I said Khaleesi. Isn't that a I mentioned Khaleesi. Tell them what you said. I said Khaleesi. Isn't that a virus? Khaleesi virus. No. It is a virus. I'm telling you, it's a virus that cats get. It is. First of all.
我说卡丽熙。那不是一个我提到了卡丽熙。告诉他们你说了什么。我说卡丽熙。那不是一个病毒吗？卡丽熙病毒。不。它是一种病毒。我告诉你，那是猫会得的一种病毒。确实是。首先。
100% is. It's called Khaleesi virus. And it's like, just I'm looking it up. Hold up. Khaleesi is Queen Daenerys Targaryen, okay? She's the Lady of Dragstone, the protector of the Seven Kingdoms, the Unburnt. You're saying nonsense to me. Feline, Khaleesi virus.
100%是。它叫卡丽熙病毒。就像是，我正在查它。等等。卡丽熙是丹妮莉丝·坦格利安女王，好吗？她是龙石岛夫人，七大王国的守护者，不焚者。你在跟我胡说八道。猫科，卡丽熙病毒。
How do you spell it? C-A-L-I-C-I, virus. Khaleesi virus is a virus of the family, Khaleesi veride, that causes diseases in cats. It's a respiratory infection. Well, this- Okay? Khaleesi is a respiratory infection in cats. This Khaleesi was married to Cal Drogo and it's spelled K-H-A-L-E-E-S-I.
你怎么拼写它？C-A-L-I-C-I，病毒。卡丽熙病毒是卡丽熙病毒科的一种病毒，会导致猫的疾病。这是一种呼吸道感染。好吧，这个——好的？卡丽熙是猫的一种呼吸道感染。这个卡丽熙嫁给了卓戈卡奥，拼写是K-H-A-L-E-E-S-I。
She's the mother of dragons. She is not a cat virus. To me, she's a cat virus. Stop it. She's not a cat virus. How dare you? Tell my cat that. Stop it. He had it. Gross.
她是龙之母。她不是猫病毒。对我来说，她是猫病毒。别闹了。她不是猫病毒。你怎么敢？去告诉我猫吧。别闹了。他得过。恶心。
All right. We're back to the episode, everybody. 11 minutes, 54 seconds. Oh my gosh. What? Ryan's talking head about how he could basically disappear from Dunder Mifflin in five seconds. Oh my gosh. What? Ryan's talking head about how he could basically disappear from Dunder Mifflin in five seconds. Yeah. Have you had a job like that? Every job I had before I became a working actor was that job. I had a temp job at Disney and I had a cubicle I never even personalized in any way. You wouldn't even know I had been there. Oh man. I engaged very little in my day jobs
好了。大家，我们回到这一集。11分54秒。哦，天哪。什么？瑞安关于他如何在五秒钟内从邓德·米夫林消失的谈话头。哦，天哪。什么？瑞安关于他如何在五秒钟内从邓德·米夫林消失的谈话头。是的。你有过那样的工作吗？在我成为职业演员之前，我做的每一份工作都是那样。我在迪士尼做过临时工，我有一个甚至没有以任何方式个性化的隔间。你甚至不会知道我去过那里。哦，伙计。我在我的日常工作中参与度很低
when I was a struggling actor. Did you not talk to people? I talked to people a little bit, but I didn't really make friends, if I'm being honest. I did not wanna put down any roots. I was Ryan. I get it, I get it. All right, at 13 minutes.
当我是一个挣扎的演员时。你不和人说话吗？我确实和人说一点话，但如果我诚实的话，我并没有真正交朋友。我不想扎根。我就是瑞安。我懂，我懂。好了，在13分钟。
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. You're jumping ahead and one of my favorite moments of the whole episode. Is what? 12 minutes, 16 seconds. One of my favorite moments of this whole entire episode. Amazing. Michael tries to make his hair look like gems.
等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。你跳得太快了，这是我整集最喜欢的时刻之一。是什么？12分16秒。我整集最喜欢的时刻之一。太棒了。迈克尔试图让他的头发看起来像吉姆的。
It's amazing. It's absolutely incredible. And then he walks around like that for the rest of the episode. It's how he wears's absolutely incredible. And then he walks around like that for the rest of the episode. It's how he wears his hair sometimes. Yeah, guys, I do this sometimes. What's the big what's the big deal at 12 minutes, 27 seconds. I have a scene with Michael. Yeah, I think my character always kept him accountable. Yeah, and he probably didn't like it. So I trying to expense his Hooters lunch. Yeah. and I'm like, this is from Hooters. And I'm like, did Toby approve it?
太棒了。这简直不可思议。然后他在这一集的其余时间里都那样走来走去。这就是他有时留头发的方式。是的，伙计们，我有时也这样做。12分27秒有什么大不了的。我和迈克尔有一场戏。是的，我想我的角色总是让他负责。是的，他可能不喜欢。所以我试图报销他的猫头鹰餐厅午餐。是的。我说，这是猫头鹰餐厅的。我说，托比批准了吗？
And he's like, I don't have to run everything by Toby. He gets really annoyed. Yes. The immediate next scene is us standing in front of Toby. I'll tell you a scene I would have loved to witness. I would have loved to see Angela then like, oh really? And march her butt across the office and Michael like running after her like, Angela, you don't have to show Toby, Angela. And I'm like, oh really? And march her butt across the office and Michael like, no, like running after her like,
他说，我不需要把所有事情都经过托比。他变得非常恼火。是的。紧接着的下一场戏是我们站在托比面前。我告诉你一个我很想见证的场景。我很想看到安吉拉当时说，哦，真的吗？然后大步走过办公室，迈克尔像是在追赶她，安吉拉，你不需要给托比看，安吉拉。我说，哦，真的吗？然后大步走过办公室，迈克尔像是在追赶她，
Angela, you don't have to show Toby, Angela. And I'm like, I am showing Toby. Toby, we'll see this receipt. And in that scene, it is revealed that his credit card was recently taken away because he made a big purchase at a magic store. He spent $80 at a magic store and his corporate card.
安吉拉，你不需要给托比看，安吉拉。我说，我正在给托比看。托比，我们会看到这张收据的。在那场戏里，透露出他的信用卡最近被收走了，因为他在一家魔术店买了大东西。他在一家魔术店花了80美元，用的是他的公司卡。
And he says he almost closed a sale by doing one of those tricks. At 12 minutes 38 seconds, when Michael is explaining this in the talking head, if you look at his thumb, he's wearing a fake magic thumb. Oh, that's a good catch. It is a delicious detail. That is a great catch. It is a delicious detail. That is a great catch.
他说他通过做那些戏法差点完成了一笔交易。在12分38秒，当迈克尔在谈话头解释这件事时，如果你看他的拇指，他戴着一个假魔术拇指。哦，那是个好发现。这是一个美味的细节。那是一个伟大的发现。这是一个美味的细节。那是一个伟大的发现。
It is in the scene at Toby's desk where Michael spills the beans about Jim's secret. He says, I'm sorry, I had to take him in lunch because Jim is in love with a girl he works with who's engaged. And Kelly overhears and says, you mean Pam? And Angela overhears and the secret is out. The secret is out. And when Michael realizes the secret is out, Steve's looked at camera. He's like dead inside.
在托比桌子那场戏里，迈克尔说漏了吉姆的秘密。他说，对不起，我不得不带他去吃午饭，因为吉姆爱上了他工作的一个女孩，而她已经订婚了。凯利无意中听到了，说，你是说帕姆？安吉拉无意中听到了，秘密泄露了。秘密泄露了。当迈克尔意识到秘密泄露时，史蒂夫看着镜头。他看起来内心已经死了。
He's like, Oh no, I've done it. And this scene was really hard to get through you guys. We kept cracking up. When we realize that it's Pam and Michael leaves, the camera pans over to Kelly and my character, and I'm sort of like biting my lip. You have a little smirky smirk. I have a smirk for information. I also was trying not to laugh.
他就像是，哦不，我做了什么。这场戏你们很难演完。我们一直在笑场。当我们意识到那是帕姆，迈克尔离开时，镜头扫向凯利和我的角色，我有点像是咬着嘴唇。你有一个小小的坏笑。我有一个为了信息的坏笑。我也在努力不笑。
Yeah. It's like all of those things. Well, the next scene is you and Phyllis cleaning out the fridge. And in this scene, Angela, when given the choice between Jim and Roy. Well, first of all, I love that I'm like, it's no one's business, Phyllis, right?
是的。就像所有那些事情。好吧，下一场戏是你和菲利斯清理冰箱。在这场戏里，安吉拉，当在吉姆和罗伊之间做出选择时。好吧，首先，我喜欢我说，这不关你的事，菲利斯，对吧？
First, I like admonish her. Like, Phyllis, stay out of it. Gosh, Phyllis. Be a better person. And then when my back is to her, I'm like, Roy. Roy. And again, it's like that same like weird arousal that we saw in the stair with Dwight. You like an alpha male.
首先，我喜欢训斥她。就像，菲利斯，别管它。天哪，菲利斯。做一个更好的人。然后当我背对着她时，我说，罗伊。罗伊。再一次，就像我们在楼梯上和德怀特看到的那种奇怪的兴奋。你喜欢阿尔法男性。
Angela Martin likes an alpha. I like, Angela Martin liked a big guy that would throw his weight around. That's right. So this leads to 13 minutes 37 seconds. This is John Krasinski's favorite line of the entire series. He lost it when he saw it when Creed says, which one is Pam? John loved Creed, the character Creed. He loves Creed and we're like but the character Creed would make John disintegrate. I traded messages with Lee Eisenberg. I said earlier, Lee wrote that line, which one is Pam?
安吉拉·马丁喜欢阿尔法。我喜欢，安吉拉·马丁喜欢一个会耍威风的大个子。没错。所以这导致了13分37秒。这是约翰·卡拉辛斯基整部剧中最喜欢的台词。当他看到克里德说，哪一个是帕姆时，他笑场了。约翰喜欢克里德，克里德这个角色。他喜欢克里德，我们就像是，但克里德这个角色会让约翰崩溃。我和李·艾森伯格交换了信息。我刚才说过，李写了那句台词，哪一个是帕姆？
And he said it is his favorite joke he ever wrote on the show. Oh, and the one he is most proud of. Oh, I think that is great. So give him all the credit for that. Way to go, Lee. At 13 minutes, 54 seconds, we have a talking head inside of Dwight's car outside of Oscar's house. Did you notice the snow on the ground? Oh, I did. I did. And I noticed the camera couldn't pan too far past the sidewalk of that house because then it was just solid green grass.
他说这是他在剧中写过的最喜欢的笑话。哦，也是他最引以为豪的一个。哦，我觉得那太棒了。所以把所有的功劳都归给他。干得好，李。在13分54秒，我们在奥斯卡家外面的德怀特车里有一个谈话头。你注意到地上的雪了吗？哦，我注意到了。我注意到了。我注意到镜头不能扫过那所房子的人行道太远，因为那样就只是坚实的绿草了。
That's right. But come on. Great production design, guys. So next we have Jim's talking head where he explains he, quote, used to have a crush on Pam. So fan question from Monica Dadashi, in this episode, when Jim says he had a crush on Pam, when she first started working at Dunder Mifflin, later in Launch Party, Jim says that when he started
没错。但拜托。伟大的制作设计，伙计们。所以接下来我们有吉姆的谈话头，他解释说他，引用，曾经暗恋帕姆。所以来自莫妮卡·达达希的粉丝提问，在这一集里，当吉姆说他暗恋帕姆时，当她刚开始在邓德·米夫林工作时，后来在发布会上，吉姆说当他开始
working there, Pam said to enjoy this moment because he could never go back to the time before he met Dwight. So which one is it? Who started working there first? Jim or Pam? Latamania and Joel Huber had a very long Twitter exchange about this continuity error.
在那里工作时，帕姆说享受这一刻，因为他永远无法回到遇见德怀特之前的时间。所以到底是哪一个？谁先开始在那里工作的？吉姆还是帕姆？拉塔马尼亚和乔尔·胡贝尔在推特上就这个连续性错误进行了很长的交流。
A lot of people wrote in about it. This is a thing. Sometimes we have things, right? The thing is, who started working there first? Bless you. Sorry. That's why you wheeled away from the microphone. Did I get far enough away from it?
很多人写信来问这件事。这是一回事。有时我们有事情，对吧？事情是，谁先开始在那里工作的？保佑你。抱歉。这就是你远离麦克风的原因。我离得够远了吗？
No. Did you get far enough away? You'd have to leave the room to be far enough away from it. I leaned back and I put, I did like the sneak in my armpit thing. If you move away from it, it doesn't make the sound cease to exist. It just makes it not like blow out your eardrums.
不。你离得够远了吗？你得离开房间才算离得够远。我向后靠，我做了那种把头埋进腋下的动作。如果你远离它，它不会让声音停止存在。它只是让它不会像炸掉你的耳膜一样。
Okay, fine. Did I not blow out your eardrums? You didn't blow out my eardrums. Thank you. Okay. You succeeded there. Continue about this heated Twitter conversation. I will. The answer is I don't know.
好吧，好吧。我没有炸掉你的耳膜吗？你没有炸掉我的耳膜。谢谢。好的。你在那里成功了。继续关于这个激烈的推特对话。我会的。答案是我不知道。
Oh. Boy, my sneeze interrupted this thing. I was feeling really bad. And then it's like, brrrr, brrrr, brrrr. I checked the Bible and everything. This is just a continuity error. That's it. There's, I don't know who started there first.
哦。天哪，我的喷嚏打断了这件事。我感觉真的很糟糕。然后就像是，呜呜，呜呜，呜呜。我查了圣经和所有东西。这只是一个连续性错误。就是这样。有，我不知道谁先开始在那里。
In one episode we say one thing, in another episode we say another. The end. The end. That's it. The end. The senator had a son we sent away and never saw again. It happens. It happens. Let's talk a little bit at 16 minutes, 45 seconds. Okay. Dwight Bus, Oscar and a male friend, Gil.
在这一集我们说一件事，在另一集我们说另一件事。结束。结束。就是这样。结束。参议员有一个我们送走后再也没见过的儿子。这会发生。这会发生。让我们在16分45秒聊一点。好的。德怀特载着奥斯卡和一个男性朋友，吉尔。
Yes. They have shopping bags. they have ice skates. Oscar is so not sick. He's not sick. And he's like, are you gonna tell Michael? And Dwight at 17 minutes, 34 seconds is like, no, I won't tell Michael in exchange for a favor from you that I will ask for at some point in the future, right?
是的。他们有购物袋。他们有溜冰鞋。奥斯卡根本没生病。他没生病。他说，你要告诉迈克尔吗？德怀特在17分34秒就像是，不，我不会告诉迈克尔，以换取你将来某个时候我会要求的一个忙，对吧？
He makes this big speech. Jenna, this made me think of a TV show that my dad watched and I watched it a few times with him called Sting Ray. It was in the 80s and Ray would show up to help someone and he would say, I will help you in exchange for a favor that I will ask of you sometime in the future. I will help you in exchange for a favor that I will ask of you sometime in the future." Do you think our writers had someone who watched Sting Ray? I'm 100 years old. None of you guys know what I'm talking about. I don't know where to start. You have nothing. I'm just telling you. I have so many thoughts. I'm telling you that first of all, I'm like astonished and delighted by the description of that show because it seems like Ray is gonna
他发表了这篇大演讲。珍娜，这让我想起了一个我爸爸看过的电视节目，我也和他看过几次，叫《魟鱼》（Sting Ray）。它是在80年代，雷会现身帮助某人，他会说，我会帮助你，以换取我将来某个时候会要求的一个忙。我会帮助你，以换取我将来某个时候会要求的一个忙。”你认为我们的编剧里有人看过《魟鱼》吗？我100岁了。你们这些家伙都不知道我在说什么。我不知道从哪里开始。你什么都没有。我只是告诉你。我有很多想法。我告诉你，首先，我对那个节目的描述感到惊讶和高兴，因为它看起来像是雷会
sting you but then help you but then call in a favor. Well I think he drives he drives a sting ray. Oh and his name is Ray? His name is Ray. He drives a sting ray. He drives a sting ray. There he is. Sam's pulling him up. Here's the description. An adventurer travels and helps people in trouble in exchange for future favors. Just like you said, it was a television series. He drove a 1965 Corvette Stingray. Was his name Ray or did you add that? No, his name is Ray.
刺你，但然后帮助你，但然后要求一个忙。好吧，我想他开，他开一辆魟鱼。哦，他的名字叫雷？他的名字叫雷。他开一辆魟鱼。他开一辆魟鱼。他就在那儿。萨姆正在调出他。这是描述。一个冒险家旅行并帮助陷入困境的人，以换取未来的忙。就像你说的，那是一个电视连续剧。他开一辆1965年的雪佛兰克尔维特魟鱼。他的名字叫雷还是你加的？不，他的名字叫雷。
The character's name is Ray? The character's name, Ray. Oh, it is. And look, it says Ray, a man of mystery, gets people out of trouble asking for favors in return. Anyway, it might not be you guys, but it definitely made me think of that. So, you know, if you have Nickelodeon
角色的名字叫雷？角色的名字，雷。哦，是。看，它说雷，一个神秘的人，让人们摆脱麻烦，以回报忙。总之，可能不是你们，但这绝对让我想到了那个。所以，你知道，如果你有尼克国际儿童频道
and there's Nick at night. Check out Stingray. Check out Stingray. Well, in this scene, it is also revealed not only that Oscar is not sick, but that he is gay, that Gil is his male companion, which Dwight completely misses. Completely misses. He doesn't see it.
而且有尼克之夜。看看《魟鱼》。看看《魟鱼》。好吧，在这场戏里，不仅透露出奥斯卡没生病，而且他是同性恋，吉尔是他的男性伴侣，德怀特完全错过了。完全错过了。他没看出来。
They cut to this scene of them all watching a movie together, which a lot of fans asked, is this the favor that Dwight, you think Dwight's gonna call back a totally different favor? I think Oscar is so relieved when he realizes that Dwight has no idea what he's stumbled across that he's like, do you want to hang out? You know, stay and hang out with us. He wants to make it a positive like, okay, bye Dwight, take care. Well you see in the background while they're watching television that Oscar reaches out and touches Gil's hand and the camera catches it.
他们切到他们一起看电影的场景，很多粉丝问，这是德怀特，你认为德怀特会回电的那个忙吗？一个完全不同的忙？我认为奥斯卡在意识到德怀特根本不知道他偶然发现了什么时感到非常宽慰，他就像是，你想一起玩吗？你知道，留下来和我们一起玩。他想让它成为一个积极的，就像，好的，再见德怀特，保重。好吧，你在背景中看到当他们看电视时，奥斯卡伸出手摸了吉尔的手，镜头捕捉到了它。
So now the audience knows that Oscar is gay, but no one in the office does, including Dwight. We had a lot of fan questions about this. So I reached out to Oscar and I asked him, when did you find out that your character was going to be gay? And he said he had heard like some rumblings from some of the writers, but he wasn't really sure. And then Greg Daniels approached him and said, hey, Oscar, we're thinking about making your character gay.
所以现在观众知道奥斯卡是同性恋，但办公室里没有人知道，包括德怀特。我们有很多关于这个的粉丝提问。所以我联系了奥斯卡，我问他，你什么时候发现你的角色会是同性恋的？他说他从一些编剧那里听到了一些传闻，但他不太确定。然后格雷格·丹尼尔斯走近他说，嘿，奥斯卡，我们正在考虑让你的角色成为同性恋。
What do you think? And that Oscar said, sounds great. I love it. And then Greg said, oh good, cause it's in the script. So there you go. Back to the episode, Jim is in Michael's office and Michael is so gutted over revealing the secret. Now, John's performance in the scene, he is so silent and he's just, it's this mixture of compassion and disappointment.
你觉得怎么样？奥斯卡说，听起来不错。我喜欢。然后格雷格说，哦，很好，因为它在剧本里。所以就是这样。回到这一集，吉姆在迈克尔的办公室里，迈克尔因为泄露秘密而感到非常痛苦。现在，约翰在这一幕中的表演，他是如此沉默，他只是，这是同情和失望的混合体。
Embarrassment. He's taking it all in. But the truth is, John could not stop laughing again. I want you to be in a small confined space with Steve Carell when he does two things, when he fake laughs or fake cries. Yeah. Because when he fake cries and he's like,
尴尬。他正在吸收这一切。但事实是，约翰又笑场了。我希望你和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在一个狭小的空间里，当他做两件事时，当他假笑或假哭。是的。因为当他假哭，他就像，
I can't laugh, it is impossible not to laugh. John couldn't handle it. He could not handle it. And then did you notice when Jim comes over and then Michael kind of like hugs his crotch? I wrote awkward crotch hug. Awkward crotch hug. Should we start tracking those? No.
我不能笑，不可能不笑。约翰受不了了。他受不了了。然后你注意到当吉姆过来，然后迈克尔有点像是拥抱他的胯部吗？我写了尴尬的胯部拥抱。尴尬的胯部拥抱。我们应该开始追踪那些吗？不。
All right. So then we have the scene in the kitchen, right? Where Jim has to confront Pam because it's going around. Well, he wants her to hear it from him and not someone else. Yeah. So Jim tells Pam, hey, you're probably going to hear this thing that I told Michael or whatever, but just I want you to know that was from a long time ago. That was when you first started. Three years ago. Three years ago. Yeah. Because at first, Pam is so happy. Yes. She's like, oh my gosh, this is amazing.
好的。所以我们有厨房里的那场戏，对吧？吉姆必须面对帕姆，因为这件事正在传开。好吧，他想让她从他那里听到，而不是别人。是的。所以吉姆告诉帕姆，嘿，你可能会听到我告诉迈克尔的那件事，或者别的什么，但我只是想让你知道那是很久以前的事了。那是你刚开始的时候。三年前。三年前。是的。因为起初，帕姆非常高兴。是的。她就像是，哦，天哪，这太棒了。
This is the conversation I wanted to have on top of Boo's cruise. Right. And then when he is just so adamant that, well, I don't feel that way anymore, then she's sad. Well, when I leave the kitchen, most of the time, they kept the shot going all the way to me getting to my desk. The door would close, and then they would do a spy shot
这是我想在游轮上进行的对话。对。然后当他如此坚持，好吧，我不再那样感觉了，然后她很伤心。好吧，当我离开厨房时，大多数时候，他们保持镜头一直拍到我走到我的桌子。门会关上，然后他们会做一个间谍镜头
of me sitting down at my desk, you would see me crying. They didn't keep it in. But I would leave and I would cry. And I, there are times when you're playing a character where you can't help but feel their feelings. And I have to say, I really felt Pam's heartbreak. I really did when we were performing the scene. It's not just that she wants Jim to admit feelings.
我坐在我的桌子前，你会看到我在哭。他们没有保留它。但我会离开，我会哭。而且，当你扮演一个角色时，有些时候你忍不住感受到他们的感受。我必须说，我真的感受到了帕姆的心碎。我真的感受到了，当我们表演那场戏时。不仅仅是她想让吉姆承认感情。
It's that she wants him to save her. She doesn't have the courage right now to save herself. And she's going to get there. And I'm glad that that's how the show is written. I'm glad that ultimately Pam saves herself. But there's all of this in her in this moment right now. And it was a really intense thing to shoot. And I'll always remember it.
而是她想让他拯救她。她现在没有勇气拯救自己。她会到达那里的。我很高兴剧本是这样写的。我很高兴最终帕姆拯救了自己。但此时此刻她心里有这一切。而且拍摄起来非常激烈。我永远会记住它。
Wow. I didn't know that they did a spy shot of you. I would have loved to have seen that. Yeah. It's not in the deleted scenes, but I remember doing it. Because I remember that walk from the kitchen to my desk feeling very, very long. And vulnerable, I'm sure. Okay, 19 minutes, 30 seconds. We are now at a scene with Michael and Pam where everything gets turned back on its head.
哇。我不知道他们拍了你的间谍镜头。我很想看到那个。是的。它不在删除的场景里，但我记得做了它。因为我记得从厨房到我桌子的那段路感觉非常，非常长。而且很脆弱，我肯定。好的，19分30秒。我们现在在迈克尔和帕姆的一场戏，一切都被颠倒了。
Yes, we think Jim is like, I've resolved it. Yeah, you've collected yourself like fine, he liked me, he doesn't like me anymore, fine. And Michael's like, oh yeah, no, it was on the booze cruise. He had a crush on you. And you're like, wait, did he tell you he had a crush on me on the booze cruise or did he have a crush on me on the booze cruise?
是的，我们认为吉姆就像是，我已经解决了它。是的，你已经整理好自己，就像好吧，他喜欢我，他不再喜欢我了，好吧。迈克尔就像是，哦，是的，不，那是在游轮上。他暗恋你。你说，等等，他告诉你他在游轮上暗恋我，还是他在游轮上暗恋我？
And Michael's like, shut it, Michael, shut it. Now everyone's leaving for the day. Pam and Jim leave together. They do. They get in the elevator together. Well, in the elevator, you notice there are all of these glances where Jim looks at me while I'm looking forward, but then I look at Jim
迈克尔就像是，闭嘴，迈克尔，闭嘴。现在每个人都要下班了。帕姆和吉姆一起离开。他们确实。他们一起进了电梯。好吧，在电梯里，你注意到所有这些瞥视，吉姆看着我，而我向前看，但然后我看着吉姆
while he's looking forward. It took us forever to time that out with getting in the elevator, glancing at each other. That was all intentional. The doors closing exactly when the doors closed. It took a very, very long time. I'm very proud of how it turned out. Also, David Calderhead wrote in and said, did you consciously lean into John in the
当他向前看时。我们花了半天时间来计算进入电梯，互相瞥视的时间。那都是故意的。门关上时，正好门关上。花了非常，非常长的时间。我为它的结果感到非常自豪。此外，大卫·考尔德黑德写信说，你在电梯里的最后一场戏中是否有意识地向约翰倾斜？我没有有意识地做。它只是发生了。但那是我们必须编排并做得恰到好处的一点舞蹈。好吧，我觉得它很棒。而且这是总结那一集故事情节的一种很好的方式。
final scene in the elevator? I didn't consciously do it. It just kind of happened. But that was a little dance that we had to choreograph and get just right. Well, I thought it was great. And it was a great way to sort of wrap up that storyline of that episode.
然后我们在20分16秒。迈克尔透露他正在看一部Cinemax电影。电影的名字叫《应召女郎的更多秘密》。是的，不是一部真正的电影。我查过了。不，一个应召女郎。是的，不是一部真正的电影。我查过了。不，它不是。它不是一部真正的电影。
And then we have it 20 minutes, 16 seconds. Michael reveals that he was watching a Cinemax movie. The name of the movie is called More Secrets of a Call Girl. Yeah, not a real movie. I looked it up. No, a Call Girl. Yeah, not a real movie. I looked it up. No, it's not. It's not a real movie.
接下来是20分16秒。迈克尔透露他当时在看一部Cinemax电影。电影的名字叫《应召女郎的更多秘密》。没错，这不是一部真正的电影。我查过了。不，应召女郎。没错，这不是一部真正的电影。我查过了。不，它不是。它不是一部真正的电影。
Michael says, you know, wait, what does he say? Does he say, I don't want to be Shila? Can we hear that? It's at 20 minutes, 16 seconds. I was watching Cinemax last weekend, this movie. Portrait of a prostitute, something. Secrets of a call, more secrets of a call girl. An elite character, Shyla, is framed for murder,
迈克尔说，你知道，等等，他说了什么？他说，我不想成为希拉吗？我们能听一下吗？在20分16秒处。上周末我在看Cinemax，这部电影。妓女的肖像，之类的。应召女郎的秘密，更多应召女郎的秘密。一个精英角色，希拉，被陷害谋杀，
goes on the run, and winds up working at a bordello in Malibu. I don't, I don't wanna live like that. I like it here. I don't wanna be Shyla. I like being Michael Scott. I don't wanna be Shyla. He doesn't wanna be Shyla. I like being Michael Scott. I don't want to be Shila. He doesn't want to be Shila. I want to be Michael Scott. That's a good quote. I don't want to be Shila. Why didn't I make people shirts with that?
开始逃亡，最终在马里布的一家妓院工作。我不想，我不想那样生活。我喜欢这里。我不想成为希拉。我喜欢做迈克尔·斯科特。我不想成为希拉。他不想成为希拉。我喜欢做迈克尔·斯科特。我不想成为希拉。他不想成为希拉。我想做迈克尔·斯科特。那是一句好台词。我不想成为希拉。我为什么没做印有那句话的衬衫呢？
I should have. You should have. I don't want to be Shila. Alright everybody, that was The Secret. And we are back next week with The Carpet. There's some gross stuff on Michael's carpet. He's going to figure out what exactly it was. See you next week. See you then. See you then. See you then. See you then.
我本该做的。你本该做的。我不想成为希拉。好了各位，这就是《秘密》。下周我们将回归《地毯》。迈克尔的地毯上有一些恶心的东西。他会弄清楚那到底是什么。下周见。下周见。下周见。下周见。下周见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins, and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weis-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office
感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本集最初是与Earwulf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室》
Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
女士由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。